lionel jospin face au mouvement des
chômeurs pas de changement de cap à de
relèvement des minima sociaux la
continuité d'une politique grève des
instituteurs en france aujourd'hui les
instits veulent être considérés comme
les professeurs des écoles dont les
salaires sont supérieurs
le livre sur le meurtre de yann piat les
accusateurs de jean claude gaudin
sévèrement condamnés à de fortes amendes
par le tribunal de marseille écologie
contre technologies ibm est accusé de
consommer l'eau des nappes phréatiques
considérés comme des réserves
stratégiques en cas d'urgence de très
fortes pollutions en france rayon font
un naufrage du titanic est en train de
battre tous les records d'affluence plus
de 3 millions de spectateurs en douze
jours d'exploitation seulement en france
le film se jouent à guichet fermé madame
monsieur bonsoir
au début de la cinquième semaine du
mouvement de protestation des chômeurs
le premier ministre lien jospin est
intervenu cet après midi à l'assemblée
nationale pour dire qu'il comptait bien
accéléré augmenter le nombre des aides
d'urgence
mais pas question pas question de
changer la politique à long terme du
gouvernement hors de question donc de
relever les minima sociaux de 15 cents
francs car dit il nous ne voulons pas
d'une société d'assistance mais d'une
société fondée sur le travail et
l'activité
lionel jospin
aussi répondre à ce que révèle cette
situation d'urgence
peut-on le faire en relevant tous les
minima sociaux de 15 cents francs par
mois
les français savent que ça n'est pas
possible
les français savent que tout n'est pas
possible tout de suite relevé de 500
francs par mois les minima sociaux pour
trois millions trois cent mille familles
signifierait un outil médias de 60
milliards de francs accordé un revenu
minimum aux jeunes de moins de 25 ans
signifierait un foot immédiate de 10
milliards de francs 70 milliards de
francs nous ne pouvons pas alourdir le
déficit budgétaire de 70 milliards de
francs nous ne pouvons pas demander aux
français de supporter des impôts
supplémentaires de 70 milliards de
francs et donc en outre mesdames et
messieurs les députés
le problème n'est pas qu'un problème
budgétaire
il faut savoir que si nous augmentions
de 70% les minima sociaux
c'est tout le problème des relations
entre ce qu'ils vivent
parce que ils ne peuvent pas faire
autrement des allocations qui sont
données et le problème de ceux qui sont
payés au smic qui se trouverait posée au
point deux déréglé l'ensemble des
relations sociales et du rapport au
travail
comment si nous augmentions le rmi de
70% pour des couples ou les couples avec
enfants cela veut dire que le revenu
serait supérieure ens me c'est à dire
supérieurs à ce que gagnent un homme ou
une femme qui vont au travail chaque
matin or le travail et dans notre
société et pour nous au coeur du lien
social
nous ne voulons pas une société
d'assistance mais une société fondée sur
le travail et l'activité productrice
enfin et surtout monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
nous allons gagner
mené et gagné la bataille pour l'emploi
c'est le succès de cette politique
conduite dans la durée dans le cap doit
être rappelée qui fera reculer le
chômage et qui fera reculer l'exclusion
ce cadre doit être maintenu il ne faut
pas compromettre son succès nous avons
été élus il ya sept mois par les
français pour engager et pour gagner la
bataille contre le chômage
nous avons été élus pour plus de justice
sociale
nous avons commencé à rééquilibrer
l'impôt sur le capital et l'impôt sur le
travail
nous allons gagner la bataille pour
l'emploi
c'est la raison d'être de cette majorité
c'est le devoir et la responsabilité de
ce gouvernement
une et donc de l'entendre l'équilibré
économique de la france ne permet pas de
relever les minima sociaux a dit le
premier ministre
un discours qui passe mal auprès de
certains chômeurs pour qui cette
revendication est la base du mouvement
réactions recueillies cet après-midi
tout de suite après discours de liens de
jospin damien thévenot philippe l'outil
nous avons déçu presque révolter sans se
faire trop d'illusions il espérait tout
de même un geste significatif du premier
ministre ce geste n'est pas venu
concrètement ils nous posent peut
strictement rien du tout j'ai rien
compris
on fait des cadeaux au patronat et les
revendications des associations de
chômeurs n'ont pas changé
1500 francs de revalorisation des minima
sociaux prime de 3000 francs et rémy
pour les jeunes de moins de 25 ans les
français ça n'est pas possible
lui nous parle de 60 milliards nous on
lui parle de survie alors qu'on ne peut
pas s'entendre
la jeunesse de france qu'on a vu un
ministre comme ça at il dit que son
gouvernement refuse de rabaisser le smic
à au moins de 25 ans qu'ils ont rien à
taper et ben tant mieux les jeunes vont
crever dans les états majors des
associations de chômeurs même déception
même inquiétude est évidemment le
premier ministre maintenait cette
position absolument fermer bien y aura
des discussions par tous et je pense
qu'il y aura 7 avant de décisions
d'action les associations de chômeurs
promet de nouvelles opérations commandos
des actions coup de poing
objectif continuer à faire pression sur
le gouvernement pour le faire changer
d'avis après les chômeurs après ce
discours les réactions les plus attendu
était pour une fois celle de la majorité
qui avaient exprimé des positions
différentes à propos du mouvement des
chômeurs pour les verts dominique voynet
réaffirmé par exemple ce matin son
soutien au mouvement des chômeurs
qu'elle considère non pas dirigée contre
le gouvernement mais au contraire comme
un point d'appui de sa politique
les communistes sans parler de crise
réclame
éclaircissement jean baptiste près dalli
olivier robert les socialistes se sont
levés pour applaudir lionel jospin
les 36 députés communistes sont restés
assis approuvant du bout des doigts
et si le premier ministre a ensuite pris
soin de souligner la cohésion de sa
majorité dans les couloirs la réponse
sur les minimas sociaux n'a pas
franchement soulever l'enthousiasmé chez
les verts et au parti communiste ya
toujours une porte entrouverte
il faut la pousser la conjugaison d'une
bien social de l'activité des
parlementaires de la majorité plurielle
avec le gouvernement peut faire en sorte
que cette porte s'ouvre un peu plus et
les chômeurs qui sont aujourd'hui dans
la rue et on représente un certain
nombre qui n'ont même plus la porte et
déplacés ils attendent autre chose que
des réponses d'urgence pour pouvoir
survivre
les alliés des socialistes dans la
majorité reste sceptique la droite elle
considère l'intervention du premier
ministre comme un non-événement
je ne crois pas que les nouveaux membres
solution valable pour les problèmes que
connaissent les français et en
particulier les chômeurs
en fait l'opposition met surtout
l'accent sur les contradictions de la
gauche
robert hue de son côté les minimise mais
cet après midi le leader du pc le
répétait l'augmentation des minima
sociaux restent à l'ordre du jour en
bref également le président du patronat
ernest antoine seillière est inquiet
tout en réaffirmant son opposition aux
35 heures il estime que le mouvement des
chômeurs peut amener le gouvernement à
durcir sa position pour s'attirer les
bonnes grâces de l'opinion publique
parmi les nouvelles mesures d'urgence
qu'envisage lionel jospin pourrait
figurer un renforcement de l'aide au
fonds de solidarité logement pour les
familles désirant accéder à la propriété
ou menacés d'expulsion pour loyers
impayés l'edf comme elle le fait déjà et
de son côté invité à faire preuve de
souplesse dans les coupures de courant
par exemple ou de chauffage il avait été
gelé à patricia charles 120 mille
familles sont menacées d'expulsion
chaque année dans 85% des cas parce
qu'elles ne peuvent plus payer leur
loyer pour les aider à se maintenir dans
les lieux les fonds de solidarité aux
logements financés majoritairement par
l'état et le département en 96 1
milliard de francs a été débloqué cette
année comme prévu le fond augmentera de
21%
c'est très largement insuffisant
aujourd'hui compte tenu du fait qu'on a
posés autour de 4 à 5 milliards
d'impayés de loyers que la majorité ces
impayés de loyers concernent des ménages
qui sont victimes du chômage et la
précarisation et qu' ils ne seront pas
en mesure de payer leurs loyers
d'autant que le rôle des fous des deux
logements n'est pas seulement d'éviter
les expulsions chaque année des sommes
importantes est aussi des familles à
s'installer où est surmontée divers
problèmes de logement les difficultés
pour régler les factures d'eau ou
d'électricité en font partie l'hiver
dernier
edf a aidé plus de 120 mille foyers en
accordant suivant les cas des sursis de
paiement ou l'engagement de ne jamais
couper grâce à un service minimum
le conseil immédiat que je donne à ses
clients en difficulté s'est
immédiatement de prendre contact le plus
vite possible avec son agence locale
edf et nous verrons avec les organismes
sociaux quels dispositifs on peut mettre
en place pour trouver avec leurs clients
une solution
cette souplesse va devenir mode de
gestion
il n'empêche
l'année dernière faute de paiement dans
le seul xviiie arrondissement de paris
neuf mille familles ont été privées
d'électricité pour en revenir aux
premières mesures d'urgence dans les
cellules d'urgence justement décidé
dernièrement par le gouvernement
quarante mille dossiers ont déjà été
déposés les premières aides financières
commencent à être versés reportage à
bordeaux sandrine albeau frédéric d'un
chèque
françoise viens de recevoir un chèque de
1000 francs de la trésorerie générale
elle est l'une des premières
bénéficiaires de l'aide d'urgence aux
chômeurs direction sa banque et me
foncent sur le compte ils seront bientôt
partie 300 francs de dire que scolaire
qui restait à régler son école de
musique de 200 enfants une partie de la
dette de loyer de 500 francs puis sa
facture de téléphone à venir donc les
mille francs sont quasiment déjà
englouti après un set et un emploi à mi
temps
françois avec au chômage depuis un mois
seule l élève un fils de 17 ans et
touche 5000 francs par mois pour
l'instant être sociales comprises les a
là des dettes mille francs pour elle
c'est une bouffée d'air ça va déjà mais
des pannes et ça méritait demande était
un peu plus et aussi me permettre d'en
chercher du travail passé quand même
priorité à tous et bon mais je pense
même investir d'argent pour une annonce
en silhouette pour une recherche
d'emploi mois qui s'appelle éteindre les
photos et cetera les cv etc
chaque jour depuis une semaine des
centaines de chômeurs remplissent des
demandes d'aidé d'urgence
plus de mille dossiers ont déjà été
envoyés à la préfecture de la gironde
ils viennent timidement et après
viennent ils ont besoin de cet argent
maintenant les médias vous en
l'occurrence perlimpinpin 10 ayessa
commencent à se débloquer les gens
commencent à y croire nous sommes là
pour ça en gironde 26 millions seront
débloqués pour les personnes en grande
difficulté
huit mille personnes pourraient en
bénéficier l'aide n'est en principe pas
renouvelable ça ne veut pas dire qu'une
autre aide ne pourrait pas être portée
d'ici quelques semaines
aux vues toujours de la situation de la
situation d'un personnel les aides vont
de 1000 à 4000 francs selon les cas mais
la revendication principale reste le
relèvement des revenus minimum pour tous
et puis en marge de cette déclaration de
politique économique et sociale à la
fois lionel jospin est revenu sur
l'incident de la semaine dernière à
propos souvenez-vous de
faire dreyfus il a comme promis présenté
ses regrets à la droite qui l'avait
présenté comme historiquement
antidreyfusard de bien belles choses pas
mon erreur venez moins d'une analyse
historique ou politique sur laquelle je
ne reviens pas mon erreur et est sans
doute d'avoir créer dans l'esprit d'un
certain nombre d'entre vous l'idée d'un
amalgame entre hier et aujourd'hui je
veux vous dire particulièrement ceux qui
s'en sont sincèrement ému que cela
n'était pas mon intention est que je le
regrette
voilà maintenant à cinq mois de la coupe
du monde de football ministre de
l'intérieur jean pierre chevènement a
présenté aujourd'hui les principaux
éléments du dispositif de sécurité qui
sera mise en place pour cet événement
6000 policiers et gendarmes
quotidiennement autour et sur le terrain
philippe visseyrias yanncik à la
découverte en avant-première pour un
spectateur engagé jean pierre
chevènement n'est pas seulement venu au
stade de france pour contempler les
architectures des lieux
le ministre de l'intérieur a choisi le
stade symbole de la prochaine coupe du
monde pour y parler sécurité est tout
d'abord sécurité à l'intérieur des
stades le retrait des grilles et
confirmé pour au moins huit des dix
stades seul saint-etienne et lens pose
problème dans ces deux villes on juge
pour l'instant qu'une telle opération
coûte trop cher ailleurs on a trouvé
diverses solutions gris modulable au
stade de france
fausse de plusieurs mètres de profondeur
à marseille bordeaux au parc des princes
la sécurité à l'intérieur du stade est
prise en charge par les organisateurs
il dispose de six mille agents nommés
stadiers mais la police peut intervenir
quand elle le juge nécessaire
dans chaque stade un réseau de
vidéosurveillance repère les
perturbateurs qui pourront être jugés en
comparution immédiate
d'ailleurs le ministre de l'intérieur
voudrait renforcer les pouvoirs de la
loi
nous avons prévu en france même non
seulement une peine d'interdiction de
stade pour ceux qui réalisent des
perturbations à l'intérieur des stades
nous allons l'étendre
pour les perturbateurs aux abords des
stades aux abords des stades près de
6000 gendarmes et policiers seront
mobilisés les jours de match des
policiers étrangers seront même présents
sur le sol français pour repérer les
hooligans ce au sein du public
ils travailleront en collaboration avec
les autorités françaises deux millions
cinq cent mille spectateurs 64 matchs
une cible potentielle pour les
terroristes
le plan vigipirate sera renforcée à
paris 350 militaires viendront compléter
un dispositif fort de mille hommes les
32 délégations officielles seront elles
protégées par des unités d'élite raid
gign gipn
si la france tient à offrir une image
conviviale de sa coupe du monde
le ministre de l'intérieur est venu
rappeler qu'il ne lésinerai pas sur les
moyens pour que tout se passe dans
l'ordre
les filles elles environ un millier de
personnes à paris aujourd'hui à
l'occasion du mouvement de grève de 24
heures des instituteurs qui réclame
l'accession immédiate au titre de
professeur des écoles qui leur
assurerait un salaire supérieur
selon le ministère la grève a été suivie
environ prendre pour 150 % selon les
syndicats cette revendication a peu de
chances d'aboutir en fait si on écoute
la réponse faite ce matin par le
ministre de l'éducation claude allègre
écoutons le je pense que cette
revendication des instituteurs à un
fonds et nous madame royal et moi même
nous n'avons nous avons une sympathie
pour se pose pour cette transformation
simplement le contexte budgétaire ne
permet pas de nous d'avoir beaucoup de
marge de manoeuvre actuellement ils ont
été voir le premier unissent le premier
à 10,0 ne pas passer des après-midi
quand même dans les écoles maintenant
cette cohabitation est effectivement
difficile à vivre dans la mesure où
instituteur maîtres des écoles qui ont
un niveau supérieur d'études font
exactement en fait le même métier
reportage dans la région de blois jean
bernard schmidt guillaume faudra des
classes vides à côté de salles où les
cours se déroulent normalement
dans cet établissement primaire l'un des
plus importants du loir et cher
la grève a été suivie par un enseignant
sur deux les enfants dont les parents
n'avaient pas réussi à s'organiser ont
donc tu es fera que guy le mouvement a
certes obligé à modifier les habitudes
mais il a souvent été compris non non je
me suis arrangé mais chercher mon
enfance exceptionnel mais j'en ai
profité je suis complètement solidaire
solidaire également ces enseignants qui
ont pourtant choisi cette fois ci de ne
pas faire grève
au coeur du problème une seule
profession mais de statut depuis 89 les
nouveaux arrivants plus diplômées
s'appelle des professeurs des écoles
d'importantes disparités de salaires les
sépare des instituteurs et professeurs
des écoles débutants gagne autant
d'argent qu'un instituteur qui sont dix
ans d'ancienneté
une situation insupportable je crois que
assentiment effectivement partagé de
belles chutes fils d'un corps divisé à
deux vitesses avec des enseignants qui
ont maintenant quelques années
d'ancienneté et qui dans une profession
qui a besoin d'être valorisés ressentent
effectivement comme une injustice le
fait de ne pas être payé sur la même
grille que des jeunes collègues qui
débute
objectif pour les instituteurs être
intégrés dans le corps des professeurs
des écoles pour cela de moyens
l'ancienneté est un concours qui leur
est ouvert mais qui n'offrent chaque
année que 2500 places
aujourd'hui ils sont plus de 200 milles
à attendre leur changement de statut et
la procédure pourrait aller jusqu'en
une échéance beaucoup trop éloigné pour
bon nombre d'instituts le mauvais temps
sur la france l'offensive de la neige
avait été quelque peu exagérée par la
météo hier sur le front des inondations
situation toujours délicate dans le lot
et garonne en revanche décrue amorcée
largement amorcée dans le sud-ouest en
dordogne et dans le lot
reportage christophe la rocca olivier
combe depuis le début de l'après midi
le lot a commencé à baisser à ko pour
les badauds c'est un hôtel la chartreuse
qui a servi d'échelle de crue grandeur
nature au plus fort de la crise jusqu'à
60 centimètres d'eau ont envahi la salle
du restaurant le lot a dépassé sa cote
dallaire
un mètre quatre-vingt trois personnes
ont dû être évacuées mais les dégâts
matériels sont limités il y environ cinq
ou six ce bâtiment qui sent qu'ils ont
été touchés la prévision encore une fois
été bonne et a permis donc de prévenir
les gens désirent après midi donc ils
ont pu évacuer les matériaux qu'ils
pouvaient être menacée donc il ya eu
pratiquement très très peu de dégâts à
figeac aussi le sait les abaisser hier
soir nous avions laissé ce monsieur à
quelques dizaines de mètres de chez lui
il ne pouvait rentrer à cause de la
montée des eaux
ce matin il a finalement pu regagner son
domicile première inspection des lieux
en compagnie de son épouse et de sa
fille née là-bas
heureusement on avait souvent de vous
envoyer des caisses de jouer fallu si
elles ont un peu souffert
j'ai inventé je m'attendais quand même
plus de dégâts notamment au niveau de la
rue
meneur ma maison bon maintenant il va
falloir retrousser les manches et puis
et puis il ya les voilà mais face aux
inondations rien ne vaut l'expérience
dans cette entreprise cela fait des
décennies que l'on travaille au bord du
lot hier soir pour se protéger les
ouvriers ont bâti un barrage simplement
avec des planches et du plâtre vous
pouvez le constater ça marche en légère
implication mais en fait ce n'est rien
par un rapport d hygiène cru il est
connu le seul problème c'est que
l'entreprise est toujours encerclée par
les flots et qu'aucun client ne s'est
encore risqué à lui rendre visite
technologie contre écologie notre
enquête de ce soir s'intéresse à l'usiné
ibm de corbeil essonnes qui fabrique
pour toute l'europe des semi-conducteurs
ce qu'on appelle des puces informatiques
qui ont besoin d'être débarrassé de la
moindre imperfection de la moindre
poussière et pour se faire bien on
utilise une eau extrêmement pur puiser à
800 mètres de profondeur ce qui pose un
véritable problème écologique car ces
nappes phréatiques à une telle
profondeur sont considérés comme une
réserve stratégique en cas de pollution
très grave dans notre pays reportage
stéphane guez jean louis goût c'est au
fond de ce puits loup la plus pure qu'on
puisse trouver dans le sous sol du
bassin parisien
nous sommes ici dans l'usiné ibm de
corbeil-essonnes sur chacun de ses
disques plusieurs milliers de micro
puces pour les produire ibm s'est engagé
dans une course à la miniaturisation et
quand on travaille à l'échelle de
l'atome une poussière et c'est la
catastrophe
c'est pourquoi pour nettoyer ses puces
ibm avait besoin de cette eau
est probable vous avez et 64 millions de
composants sur chaque puce chaque puce
et isolé des autres paris l'épaisseur
d'oxydé de nord de grandeur de 20 at
home une impureté eux rentrent donc
défaillante
cette puce est donc les faits une
contamination serait tout bonnement de
détruire toutes les puces donc nos
rendements de production
c'est aussi parfaite ibm va la puiser à
800 mètres de profondeur dans une nappe
souterraine vieille de cent millions
d'années une réserve d'eau potable
déclaré en 96 d'importance stratégique
donc censée être préservée
pourtant ibm continue de pomper cette
richesse souterraine en vertu d'une
autorisation préfectorale exceptionnel
que conteste aujourd'hui la lyonnaise
des eaux
il faut 25 mille ans pour qu'une goutte
d'eau une goutte d'eau de pluie
réalimente la nappe compte tenu de ce
taux de renouvellement extrêmement
faibles il faudra des années pour
recharger la nappe en quantité et donc
on va entamer le volume est existante de
cette réserve pour l'eau potable
un rapport de l'académie des sciences
souligner les conséquences écologiques
de ses pompages la nappe utilisé par ibm
alimenterait par infiltration un autre
bassin placé plus haut celui de l'albien
dont l'eau potable est elle fortement
exploitée depuis de nombreuses années la
diminution du niveau inférieur
empêcherait le renouvellement de ce
bassin bien sûr les pompages du bm n'y
suffisent pas mais son exemple pourrait
créer un précédent
on voit aujourd'hui les enquêtes
publiques s'ouvrir de la part de
différentes industries qui souhaitent à
leur tour pompée dans cette nappe
on risque de devoir un bien collectif
un patrimoine commun confisquées aux
pour des intérêts privés la société ibm
pourra-t-elle continuer ses pompages le
préfet de l'essonne doit le décider
d'ici mars
il devra arbitrer entre deux logiques la
course à l'innovation les 3000 emplois
dits bm ou la protection d'un patrimoine
aussi pure que précieux c'est sur une
piste privée près de montpellier que
mercedes présente pendant 48 heures
après 2 500 journalistes spécialisés son
modèle mercedes classe a
qui a connu tant de problèmes
souvenez-vous problèmes de stabilité
lors de ses premières sorties en octobre
dernier pour la firme allemande l'enjeu
est de taille
sauver un modèle qui a demandé des
centaines de millions d'investissements
et pour convaincre aujourd'hui
et bien tout est parfaitement réglé
mercedes n'a pas lésiné sur les moyens
l'ugb aziza frédéric basque invitation
chez mercedes sous ces tentes installées
au coeur du circuit automobile de
mireval dans l'hérault la fameuse petite
classe a revu et corrigé à temps les
journalistes nous sommes une quarantaine
en guise d'accueil une conférence de
presse où le responsable allemand au
sourire un peu tendu nous fait une
citation de confucius celui qui commet
une erreur et ne la corrige pas est une
seconde erreur
pendant ce temps rien n'est laissé au
hasard sur la piste un arrosage
permanent permet par exemple de mieux
tester l'adhérence
histoire de prouver l'efficacité d'un
système électronique esp empêchant toute
sortie de route
aujourd'hui ça ressemble un peu à un
parc d'attractions quand même on a des
ateliers où on nous met en situation la
voiture sous sur sur sol mouillé sur
chaussée un peu dégradée etc
mais ça ressemble pas du tout à ce que à
ce que ça de ce que ça devrait être
c'est à dire des essais tuto libre au
total cinq types d'exercices sont
réservés aux journalistes du slalom au
difficile test suédois de l'élan nous
allons faire maintenant le test de
l'élan le fameux test qui s'était passé
d'une façon infructueuse en suède où le
journaliste qui s'était retourné était à
une vitesse de 65 km heure là nous
sommes à 70 km/heure et le système esp
vient de s'enclencher en fait permettant
de repositionner la voiture sur la ligne
droite
donc on voit que ce système permet
effectivement de pallier aux déficiences
éventuelles de la voiture pour rattraper
techniquement le dérapage de son premier
lancement et retrouver son étoile
mercedes a dépensé un milliard de francs
pour le faire savoir 450 journalistes
parce qu'on est ici en deux semaines
le constructeur affiche déjà son
optimisme la classe s d'une voiture qui
est appelé à une longue vie et donc à
terme oui
merci laisse gagnera de l'argent sur ses
produits comme elle le fait nous sommes
là pour ça c'est une entreprise comme
les autres qui est chargé de faire du
bénéfice
comble de l'humour mercedes a offert à
chaque journaliste cet élan en peluche
symbole du fameux test
les deux auteurs et l'éditeur du livre
sur la sphère yann piat du meurtre de
yann piat qui mettait indirectement en
cause jean claude gaudin et françois le
tard comme commanditaire du meurtre ont
été sévèrement condamnée aujourd'hui à
marseille 200 mille francs d'amendé
chacun et solidairement 300 mille francs
de dommages et intérêts à jean claude
gaudin qui avait porté plainte jacques
cardoze vincent des ans jean michel
vernhes condamné d'une peine lourde
exemplaire jamais prononcé dans le cadre
d'un délit en diffamation mais cela ne
suffit pas à ébranler l'un des deux
auteurs du livre à scandale car verne
persiste et accuse même s'il vient
d'être condamné pour la deuxième fois en
quatre mois et devant deux juridictions
différentes
je voudrais dire que nos politiques qui
aujourd'hui ont peut-être l'intention de
sabrer le champagne devant des fortunes
de deux journalistes devraient se
dépêcher de vider leurs coûts je dis à
ces gens là à ceux d'entre eux qui sont
impliqués dans l'assassinât de yann piat
et dans l'assassinât des frères ça ce
n'est qu'ils n'échapperont pas leur
destin j'en suis convaincu
et pourtant la justice a donné tort à
jean michel vernhes par deux fois
d'abord à l'automne le tribunal des
référés constate le manque de preuves et
ordonne le retrait des passages accusant
précisément les politiques
aujourd'hui le tribunal correctionnel
estime la diffamation caractérisée en
prononçant une peine inhabituel
nous sommes dans l'une des affaires où
l'on a prononcé les dommages et intérêts
les plus élevés depuis que le délit de
diffamation existe ce sont des gens qui
ont eu un dévoiement dans leur
comportement qui a été plus légers
sévèrement à raison de l'ampleur des
conséquences
l'ampleur du retentissement de ce que
leurs propos inconsidérés ont laissé
comme grâce dans la mémoire des
populations et les déboires judiciaires
de l'éditeur flammarion et des deux
auteurs ou jaunes et verts ne sont
peut-être pas terminée car après la
plainte de jean claude gaudin c'est
celle de françois léotard qui sera
examiné les 11 et 18 février prochains
l'actualité internationale comme on s'y
attendait la visite de trois ministres
européens alger a surtout permis au
gouvernement algérien de limiter la
discussion au terrorisme et de demander
aux européens de mieux surveiller les
réseaux dans leur pays notamment en
angleterre pour le reste et bien les
algériens déclarent qu'ils n'ont besoin
de rien ni de personne
pour autant cette journée a été une
nouvelle fois marquée par deux attentats
meurtriers dont un en plein centre
d'alger alors que les ministres
européens étaient encore sur place en
porte à jérôme baugnies jean-françois
rue cet après midi au moment où le chef
britannique de la délégation européenne
rencontre la presse internationale pour
évoquer une mission difficile auprès du
gouvernement algérien on apprend que les
terroristes ont frappé au coeur d'alger
dans le terminus de ben aknoun une bombe
artisanale placée dans un autobus
vivement les gens sont tenues plus
esplanade c'était vraiment pas savoir
quand dans l'hôpital voisin les soins
apportés aux victimes de violences font
partie d'une triste victime mais c'est
le premier attentat à l'explosif et aux
alger depuis le début du ramadan suivi
d'un autre il y à quelques minutes à
zéralda à l'ouest de la capitale
parmi les blessés un contrôleur du bus
qui avaient des consignes de vigilance
qu'il revenait de blessure ne sont
montés pour pour 20 pour un contrôle une
fois que la rentrée du contrat comme
bilan à ben aknoun un mort et 25 blessés
en faisant son point de presse le chef
de la délégation européenne
il n'a dû se demander si ces attentats
avaient un rapport avec sa visite
il a regretté que le gouvernement
algérien n'accepte pas la venue d'un
rapporteur spécial des nations unies
après les récents massacres
la mission européenne a été perturbé par
cet attentat dans l'autobus que
maintenant après ce premier contact tout
le travail reste à faire pour trouver à
bruxelles les moyens de maintenir le
dialogue avec alger dans la lutte contre
le terrorisme
les algériens l'ont dit aux européens
ils sont surtout inquiets de la présence
donc en europe et en angleterre en
particulier de leader islamiste qu'il
soupçonne d'abriter de véritables
réseaux terroristes l'ombre etienne
jusqu'à ces dernières semaines
abou hamza était le responsable d'al
azhar un bulletin qui reproduisaient les
communiqués du groupe islamique armé
dont il est un partisan déclaré alain
sars imprimées et distribuées à londres
sans aucune interdiction des autorités
britten les britanniques savent laisser
un espace de liberté ils sont très
intelligents pour ça ils comprennent que
pour éviter des explosions de colère il
faut donner la possibilité aux hommes
d'exprimer leurs idées d'autres pays et
la france en fait partie
ne comprennent pas cela dans son
bulletin et sur le site internet qu'il a
créé abou hamza lance régulièrement des
appels à la guerre sainte
une guerre qui en afghanistan lui a
coûté ces deux avant-bras soupçonnés à
plusieurs reprises d'être liés aux
campagnes terroristes qui ont ensemble
lente et la france il continue de
justifier la violence si les hommes les
musulmans qui se battent en algérie
considère que la france est aux côtés du
gouvernement algérien dans cette guerre
cette guerre où l'on tue leur famille
après tout c'est bien leur
responsabilité de frapper aussi la
france là où ils le peuvent pour ses
déclarations et ses justifications du
terrorisme les islamistes qui réside à
londres ne sont jamais inquiétés tant
qu'ils ne dérangent pas l'ordre public
face aux critiques de pays comme
l'algérie ou l'egypte mais aussi et
peut-être surtout face aux remontrances
régulière quoique discrète de ses
voisins européens la grande-bretagne
s'est toujours abrité derrière sa
tradition de tolérance
il y a peu de temps encore le
gouvernement britannique a promis de
voter une loi pour interdire sur son
territoire la collecte de fonds destinés
aux organisations terroristes
mais jusqu'à maintenant ces promesses
n'ont débouché sur rien sur le chemin de
washington où il doit rencontrer belfin
tonnes yasser arafat le président de
l'autorité palestinienne s'est arrêté à
paris pour rencontrer jacques chirac
puis lionel jospin
pour le président français la situation
actuelle est une sorte de défi aux
droits de l'homme à vivre en paix et
elle est très dangereuse pour israël de
son côté yasser arafat dément qu'il est
appelé à une nouvelle guerre des pierres
et à washington où il est déjà arrivé
benyamin nétanyahou n'est pas disposé du
tout accélérer le redéploiement des
forces israéliennes dans les territoires
palestiniens il est membre ou président
américain jean paul ii arrivera demain à
cuba cette fois ci on y est
cet événement est considéré la bac comme
le plus important depuis l'arrivée au
pouvoir d'un autre d'une autre figure
charismatique fidel castro s'était il y
à 39 en reportage à l'achat
la havane ces maisons coloniales et
crépis ses vieilles voitures américaines
bichonner et son peuple bien sûr la
havane retient son souffle et attend le
pas l'événement le plus important du
pays dit on depuis la révolution il y à
39 ans le christ monumentale qui ornera
précisément la place de la révolution où
se déroulera la grand messe de dimanche
prochain
et parce que mon p il fait face à che
guevara les fidèles ne se sont pas fait
prier pour apporter leur obole à
l'église même cette centenaire qui n'est
pourtant pas pas crésus
on les a mené un brief et ils
connaissent les l'erreur du parc parker
et seront là pour accueillir jean paul
ii et brandir les petits drapeaux du
vatican et de cuba que l'on prépare
depuis des semaines dans la cour du
couvent d'à côté avec foi et espérance
l'espérance surtout de plus de joie et
d'union entre tous les cubains entre
chrétiens et non-chrétiens les non
chrétiens ce sont eux l'état-major du
comité de défense de la révolution du
quartier cdr numéro 12 réunions
d'état-major pour débattre de cette
visite pontificale pas toujours évidente
à comprendre pour les camarades elle se
produit dans un moment très important de
la révolution cubaine avec
l'effondrement du camp socialiste le
débat glisse et l'idéologue du cdr met
tout de suite les choses au point
j'en prends pas que le pape était
responsable de la chute du camp
socialiste
voilà le débat est clos sur la question
et on peut donc passer à la conclusion
on nous mobiliserons en masse nous
inviterons les gens du quartier
accueillir le pape
ça tombe bien puisque le lendemain la
télévision castro a dit la même chose et
qui plus est qu'il irait lui aussi à la
messe anton en france avec la haute
couture de l'été prochain aujourd'hui
chanel marqué par un retour à la
simplicité et christian lacroix qui
revisite des siècles passés les deux
collections vu par un mannequin cette
origine à la mannequin qui a défilé pour
les deux couturiers sophie mais elle
bernhard kohl à 8 heures du matin rue
cambon dans les appartements de
mademoiselle chanel
esther de jaume 23 ans hollandaise vient
d'arriver avec pour tout bagage son
minois de porcelaine deux heures seront
nécessaires pour préparer la
cinquantaine de mannequins qui comme
elle aujourd'hui feront vivre la
collection avec maquillage espère le
maire et diam's il y en a les mêmes pour
six ans car à 70 millions de francs sur
ce parcours du combattant
alors forcément les robes s'autorise un
peu de discrétion plus les autres font
leur show du théâtre et plus karl
lagerfeld se drape dans une simplicité
ici version charleston qui on le sait
est parfois ce qu'il ya de plus dur à
maîtriser
changement de décor direction le défilé
suivant on efface tout et on recommence
pendant que christian lacroix offre une
visite guidée de ses coulisses à la
rédactrice en chef de vogue usa il était
une fois c'est avec ces mots que
christian lacroix a compté sa collection
il était une fois des faits aux robes
impalpable aussi légère qu'un soufflé
qui tiendrait sur le corps comme par
enchantement les centaines d'heures de
travail se font oublier et reste la
poésie des césars en échappée d'une
toile de maître
à l'aube de l'an 2000 de presque ce
n'est pas des tenues de cosmonautes dans
en vinyle qui font la modernité mais je
crois qu'il ya un moyen d'accommoder le
passé qui est très jeune le vern qui en
fera d'une manière bien plus virulente
aucune combinaison que le stade nyonnais
s'est tous dit christian lacroix la
couture est un plaisir égoïste et si ces
femmes n'existe que dans ses rêves c'est
déjà beaucoup
comment transformer un naufrage en
véritable triomphe est bien en réalisant
le film titanic sorti il y a deux jours
à peine en france il a déjà pulvérisé
tous les records plus de 3 millions
d'entrées ce film le plus cher du monde
rejoint dans la légende du cinéma autant
en emporte le vent à paris et bien le
film se jouent à guichet fermé il faut
retenir plusieurs jours à l'avancé place
si on veut en avoir stéphane haumant
jean luc boussard quelle revanche pour
le navire maudit il y à 85 ans il fut
victime d'un iceberg
aujourd'hui il provoque un raz de marée
grâce à la critique et au bouche à
oreille le film séduit à la fois les
cinéphiles et un public épisodique sur
plus de 500 salles un vrai succès
populaire sans distinction d'âge si vous
avez une clientèle d'adolescents ou une
clientèle de gens âgés la spa mélange et
on a surtout un phénomène qui est très
très rare
depuis un certain nombre d'années c'est
que les gens reviennent c'est à dire
qu'ils viennent voir le film ils sortent
sains d'esprit ampleur encore pleurant
et on les voit revenir on les voit
revenir très rapidement le grand rex à
paris a déjà attiré trente mille
spectateurs
le dernier succès comparable remonte à
89 c'était le grand bleu de luc besson
ailleurs mieux vaut réserver les séances
sont complètes
dès la veille
bien
les producteurs ont longtemps cru qu'ils
allaient sombrer avec leur film trop
long 3h20 trop fou un an de tournage et
surtout trop cher un milliard et demi de
francs
le réalisateur james cameron a même dû
abandonner son cachet puis ses bénéfices
pour prouver sa bonne foi devant les
dépassements de budget aujourd'hui les
studios pousse un soupir de soulagement
jamais on n'aurait pensé y de fer en
douze jours 3 millions sa semelle entre
eux je n'ai jamais avec les 115 ans de
métier à titre de comparaison danse avec
les loups
le précédent record pour un film de plus
de trois heures était de 500 mille
entrées sur la france en deux semaines
six fois moins
sur un mythe universel titanic mêle
histoire d'amour intimiste et saga
historique mélo et épopée il ratisse
large et devrait rejoindre très vite
star wars
hilti ou jurassic park en tête des box
office historique
il va forcément y avoir un après titanic
parce que c'est un tremblement de terre
la bassine catastrophe commence aux
états unis la fox pronostique un
milliard de dollars de recettes finales
sur le film donc qu'est ce qui se passe
à hollywood b comme d'habitude ils
perdent pas de temps et maintenant il ya
un galles qui courra au lieu des gens
pas de film à moins de 200 millions de
dollars aux récents golden globes
attribué par la presse d'hollywood
titanic a raflé quatre prix dont
meilleur film et meilleure mise en scène
mais le véritable objectif ce sont les
oscars leonardo dicaprio dit on est
favori
avant nous quitter le rappel des
principaux titres de l'actualité de ce
mardi d'abord lire et j'ose pas face au
mouvement des chômeurs pas de changement
de cap a dit le premier ministre
pas de relèvement des minimas sociaux de
15 cents francs comme demandé la
continuité d'une politique grève des
instituteurs en france aujourd'hui un ce
type doit l'être sans attendre
considérés comme les professeurs des
écoles dont les salaires sont supérieurs
voilà dans un instant la météo sophie
davant 20h50 le grand blond avec une
chaussure noire
c'est pierre richard demain aux quatre
vérités à 7h50 un invité exceptionnel
pour françoise laborde qui recevra le
général russe alexandre lebedev voilà je
vous souhaite une excellente soirée sur
notre chaîne bonsoir allemand
je
illégaux rallye